eu vou mostrar para a nossa área quando
fase a seleção bem mais fácil vencer a
seleção até que foi descartada mas o
motorista tiago o de lavar
primeiramente o felipão tem ensinado que
não se ganha a copa só com nem aí vocês
vão ver a seleção jogar direito
brasil vence e finalmente a taça na mão
barulho não merecia
depois de ver que a seleção não é só
neymar tem uma rua adorando 17 ele jogar
vocês um beijo 17 corrente cujo navio
disse que até minha avó que tem mais de
70 anos morrem mais que você tem muita
coisa que ainda pode ser mudada para que
o brasil não tome mas nenhuma lava aí
vocês vão ver jovens não só à viola por
um brasil vence porque hoje a gente
nosso lado de lavar da bm e não vamos
ser pobre tem começa logo a chegar
porque de casa é muito fácil falar e até
deodoro e olha o camilo mmx chora que a
gente sabe que o nosso gol de honra foi
o do oscar
[Música]